- Okay, I'm back with
soon-to-be rockstar
Salem (audience cheers)
and sitting in with my band y'all all day
has been legendary drummer Sheila E.
She's joining me over
on the couch right now.
What's up, Sheila?
- Hi, how are you?
- I'm so good.
I'm so happy you're here.
I said this in rehearsals,
we're so honored to have you.
You look like a total rock goddess
and your outfit.
I love you!
- Thank you.
- So how's it going with my band?
Are they keeping up with you?
- They're not bad for a bunch of guys.
No, just kidding. (laughs)
(Kelly laughs and people clap)
- I love Sheila.
Well, thank you again,
I mean, just for, for coming, for
♪ Regular rock ♪
(rock music)
(Kelly laughs)
You're gonna keep doing it
'cause it brings me joy.
So you heard me ask John like
what rock music means to him?
Like what about you?
Like when you think of someone say,
"Oh, you're, you're a rock star."
Like, what does that mean?
- Wow, interesting
because you know,
music has evolved so much,
you know, from the beginning of
what was rock and roll, I mean.
But it's, to me it's R&B,
it's country.
I mean, I agree with a lot of
the things that he has said
you know, it's real,
it's heartfelt, you know,
and I always want to be in a rock band.
I always wanted to play,
be the girl drummer in a rock band.
It's like one of the
things on my bucket list.
And, and it was interesting because
at one point I didn't want to be Sheila E,
the leader anymore.
I was like,
I want to go play drums
and I told Prince.
I said, "I'm going to go play drums
with some other people.
I just want to play rock"
and he say, "you want to start a band?"
and we did Sign o' the Times
and I was like
♪ Now playing drums ♪
Yeah, I love it.
So rock and roll to me is just like,
you know passion.
It's, it's heartfelt.
It's R&B.
It's blues.
It's everything.
- I know, I agree too.
There's so many emotions in it.
It can be very sweet.
It can be...
you know, Wild Horses,
it could be something very sexy.
It can be, it can be so many emotions.
I think it's just, you gotta be all in.
So what initially got
you into music though,
cause I know it runs,
It's your family right?
- Yeah.
My dad, Pete Escovedo,
legendary percussionist.
Amazing.
Still playing and actually
we played last week
for breast cancers,
raising money last week.
So it was good
we're still playing together.
My daddy.
Yes. He's so awesome.
He's 85 now and he's
still killing the game.
He's amazing. (audience claps)
- I love that.
- Yeah.
So what did you think,
cause you mentioned Prince a minute ago
and what did you think the
first time you met Prince?
- Well, it's interesting
cause my dad at the time in the seventies,
I met Prince in '77.
My dad was with Santana at the time,
my dad and my uncle,
they played with Santana.
And my dad came home and said,
"There's this young kid in the studio,
in the same studio as us.
And like, he's playing
all the instruments,
he's producing and is incredible.
His name is Prince."
So it was like,
I want to come by the studio, daddy.
And he is like,
"No, we're working,
you can't come."
So anyway,
- Boo.
- (laughs) I know.
So next you know,
I went to his concert the first time.
So I went backstage to say hello
and he was combing his hair
and he saw me and he's like, "Hi."
And I said,
"Oh, I want to introduce myself."
He said, "I already know who you are.
I'm a fan,
I'm following you.
You're amazing."
- What?
- Yeah, cause he saw me
playing drums on television
and like
- That's amazing!
- Yeah, was really cool.
And I, so we exchanged
numbers and that was it.
That was the beginning of like
a long, forever relationship.
- I mean an amazing one.
Well, Salem, do you have
a question for Sheila?
- I do actually.
So I just really want to know like
who inspired you to play drums
and song write and do all this stuff?
- My dad did and being around my family.
My dad being a percussion player,
we had a lot of amazing musicians
come to the house all the time.
So there were jam sessions.
We would sit down and play.
I watch my dad play a lot.
The first time I played with my dad,
I was five.
But I wanted to be a track star.
I was running track.
I was training to be in the Olympics
- [Kelly] Oh, wow!
- and that's what I wanted to do.
But then my dad, you know,
he was playing a lot
and I loved music.
And next thing you know,
he said, " Well,
my other percussion player was sick
so we need to substitute him."
And I was like,
I know all the music I could do it,
and I was 15.
And how old are you now?
- I'm 14. (chuckles)
- Ah, good, good time.
Yeah, go take it.
I went on tour at 15
and I never came back.
- That's awesome!
- That was it.
- 15?
- 15.
- Wow!
- I went on the road.
- That was it.
- That would be great.
- Her mom is in the back right now,
going "Nope... "(laughs)
(people clap)
- I'm gonna tell her that.
- I know it's unfortunate now
that we can't even be
on the road right now.
But I agree though
there is something that's so
interesting about that age.
Even working with people on The Voice,
like artists,
it's an interesting age
because you are so bold.
You are unaware of another way to be
and it's such a beautiful
time to create, I think,
and to be around artists your age.
It's a really cool thing.
I think we always think,
"Oh, they're young."
No, I'm like,
yes, but sometimes they
know way more than you think
and they know it because
it's innate in them
and they haven't imitated
anything yet, you know?
So I want to talk about this
cause you've got a MasterClass right?
- I do.
- Yeah, that's huge!
- I know.
Oh my god!
So anybody who's at home
you can go on MasterClass
and you go online
and you can learn how to play,
taught by me in a way that
is not ordinary, you know?
Cause I grew up, self-taught,
watching my dad play.
- Yeah.
- So I teach you how to play
by playing on your lap,
playing on the couch,
playing in the kitchen
like you don't have to buy
a bunch of gear, you know.
Don't worry about
spending money, you know.
You got pots and pans in the kitchen,
the spoons, the forks.
We played...
That's how I started.
I played on pots and pans,
my lap, the couch,
the table, everything.
- Hey, that's a clever.
A lot of people are at home right now
with nothing to do
and their dream to learn that.
So that's amazing.
- Thank you.
- Well, thank you again
for playing with us today.
It's such an honor to have you.